[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone
my name is eric normand
and today i'm going to talk about
functional programming and how you can
use it to improve testing reuse and
maintenance in your existing code base
regardless of if you're using a
functional programming language this
should apply no matter what
okay so today i hope you come away with
a new perspective on programming
that you can apply to your code new
skills for writing better software and
some curiosity to
seek out more you know this is only an
hour
and so there's no way i could give you
everything
uh that there is about functional
programming but
i hope that it inspires you to go find
some more
so i'd like to start with a little story
back in 2013 i started a meetup all
about functional programming with some
friends here in town and
every week
as or as monthly every month
the
discussion would always
go to one of these basic questions about
functional programming the big one was
what is functional programming because
we'd have new people coming in all the
time they were curious
and so that was a big you know like
almost every time we talked about what
is functional programming
they also had questions like why should
i care like i already know how to
program why
how will this help me
um
another question was should i just
rewrite everything in fp like is this an
all or nothing thing
another question was well i already know
javascript can i just do fp and
javascript
or for that matter can i learn fp in
javascript
without having to like learn a new
language
and
after these discussions
uh i
felt like i had a pretty good grasp on
at least what i thought was important
to explain to people and to
uh be able to
um you know
to to teach what what we did as
functional programmers i've been
programming in functional languages for
about 20 years now
and
it's not a very common thing
and so it there i need a lot of
explanation and people would ask me what
should i read what should i go do and i
could not recommend a book
so
i had to write it myself
and the book is groking simplicity it is
published by manning as you've probably
guessed
there's a coupon code if you would like
to buy it on the manning site you get 40
percent off just use that link and that
coupon code when you check out so
grocking simplicity is my attempt
to
uh
take
this
this idea of functional programming
that's been kind of stuck in academia at
least in terms of how it's discussed in
books
and give it to people
like from a perspective of practical
commercial software not academia
and to do that
i had to come up with a perspective on
it that would allow me to teach it
without because i can't teach the whole
thing
so i eventually
wound up
looking at functional programming as a
set of skills
uh
so if you look at this venn diagram on
the left we have
this orange circle that is things
non-functional programmers do
then the circle on the right is the
things functional programmers do so
these are different skill sets there's a
lot of overlap
a lot of the stuff that functional
programmers do you'll do you know
everyone will do but then there's some
difference
and that difference is what needs
teaching
and so that's what i focused on in the
book these are the things that
professional
functional programmers do
that other like non-functional
programmers
don't do
all right and then i had to come up with
a linear
order and a kind of organization scheme
for how this is going to work so i've
i've discovered that there's really two
levels these levels kind of correspond
to
your
your your level as a programmer
but because the second level requires
the first one
in certain ways and the first one is
actually like necessary
for the paradigm so we're going to start
there we're going to go over both of
these two levels
there's two parts of the book
that
that you know correspond to the two
levels
and we're going to start with the first
one
so part one
is all about distinguishing actions
calculations and data to my mind this is
a fundamental
difference
in functional programming versus other
ways of programming
functional programmers distinguish these
three categories so we're going to go
over
what each of them is
and
and then
the next bullet we're going to look at
how actions kind of spread through our
code and then lastly we're going to do a
refactoring to extract out a calculation
from an action
so let's get started with distinguishing
actions calculations and data
so we can imagine a code base and we
pluck some
code out of that code base
and we'll see stuff like this
so the first thing is a little bit of
json
it turns out to be a json object then
there's this function called send email
there's a function called sum there's
save user db string length get current
time and then this array of numbers
now i've starred three of these
functions
because they're different from the
others
in that
it matters
very much how many times i call them or
when i call them
so for instance send email if i call
that two times the email is going to get
sent twice
and i don't want that to happen so i put
a star next to it just to indicate it's
different whereas if i have sum
i can sum the numbers as many times as i
want it's not going to
affect the outside world
right so you can imagine how send email
would be harder to test because you
might want to run send email
20 times to run 20 different tests
and now you have to deal with you know
am i actually sending these emails
likewise save user db
it depends if you call it zero times
it's very different from calling it one
time
and then get current time every time you
call it it's going to give you a
different time
so
this is uh
these all get a star they depend on when
they are run or how many times they're
run
so functional programmers will put all
those starred functions above the line
and
we'll call those actions
okay that's the term
i came up with that i'm using in these
slides and in my book
uh this
we'll talk about
what functional programmers generally
call these later
but we'll call them actions for now so
now there's everything else under the
line and there's a difference between
just bits of data
and a function that you can run
so we'll draw another line
so that the
below the line will be data and then
above that line between actions and data
is calculations so calculations are
actually things that you can run they're
functions or operations and you know
operators like addition or
multiplication that don't have an effect
on the outside world they're just
computations
and then the data are inert things so
let's go over each one and like
give precise definitions
so actions
if you look it up in the dictionary
one definition you might find is the
process of doing something typically to
achieve an aim and i think that that
captures what actions are all about
um they're
they're trying to do something
uh external it's not just thinking about
it it's actually doing the thing
we call them in fp jargon you might have
heard these terms before impure
functions effects
or side effects
so
this is the these are the terms that
you'll hear
outside of these slides in my book
i use the term actions because
i
think that these are misleading and
confusing
uh when you're when you're a beginner so
for instance function
is
um
it's it's both a like a mathematical
concept and a language feature and
they're different
uh and then effect it's not a great term
because it's actually
the
uh we're talking about the cause so the
cause of the of the email being sent
is
the function that's called send email
the effect is the actual
email that arrives in your inbox right
so it's not quite the effect it's the
cause but then cause isn't the right
word either okay so i had to i had to
come up with my own term okay and then
there is a rule of thumb for identifying
them actions depend on when you run them
or how many times you run them when you
run them that's like the order that you
run the actions in
and then how many times you run them
that's repetition so if you call it zero
times one time two times uh what happens
there
okay
next we have calculations
dictionary definition is computation
from inputs to outputs
these are
in fp jargon we're going to call them
pure functions or referentially
transparent functions
again it's problematic because in a lot
of languages they are not implemented as
functions
i mentioned before the addition operator
plus
times divide those are calculations
they're
pure they don't have any
side effects they're not actions but
they're not functions either
so i came up with this term calculations
and they are
eternal outside of time i mean imagine
addition it's never going to change any
machine you run addition on it's going
to give you the same answer
forever you know you can't imagine it
changing if it does change we'll be in
big trouble
okay data
facts about events
used as a basis for reasoning discussion
or calculation
so data is kind of the most boring of
them
because they're inert
but i think they're actually quite
interesting in themselves
they're serializable they're
self identical
meaning they are what they are
which is kind of interesting you know a
function is kind of opaque you don't
know what it's going to do really until
you call it whereas data you can read it
but the downside of data is that they
require interpretation so you need
software to
to parse it and and and make assumptions
about what it means in order to
to use the data
so we're going to talk mostly about
actions and calculations
because data is not there's not as much
to say
the big distinction is when you're
writing code so
the thing is
functional programmers
try to write way more calculations than
actions like more code should be in your
calculations than actions
basically as much as possible in
calculations actions only when necessary
why because
actions depend on time and
it's just a pain to work with they're
much harder to deal with as we'll see
the thing is though that we pay much
more attention to actions we spend more
time with actions because they are
harder to work with this is kind of a
common misconception
in functional programming that we don't
want to use actions at all
or
that
you know we we basically try to to
ignore them we actually spend a lot more
time and are a lot more attention
making sure that our actions run
correctly
and i think we spend it more than other
paradigms so it's kind of interesting
that there's that kind of duality spend
more code on calculations but then more
attention on actions to make sure
they're right
all right we're going to talk about the
spreading rule
so
let's imagine this programmer
has some code
and
she can correctly identify that this
function called send payout is an action
we should go through what the code does
so down at the bottom there's the main
function
and
it calls affiliate payout with the
affiliates
affiliate payout is going to loop
through all the affiliates
and then call figure payout for each one
and figure payout is going to multiply
the sales from the affiliate times the
commission
and if they're owed more than a hundred
dollars it's going to send the payout
meaning it's going to contact the bank
and transfer money to their account
so obviously send payout is an action
it's
physically or you know it's it's
reaching out to another system and
sending money to them so if you call it
twice
it's a it's a big deal you're you're
giving too much money
but it's the rest of her code actions
she claims it's only got this one so
let's apply the spreading rule
and we'll learn it as we go so we'll
start with that one highlighted action
now one rule of the spreading rule
or one part of the spreading rule
is that
a
function that calls an action must
itself be an action
because now if i call figure payout
twice
well that's going to send the payouts
twice too
so figure payout also is an action
because that's an action we have to
highlight the place where it is called
in the next function
but again we can continue
you know recursively applying this rule
oh sorry you can't read that down there
we can continue recursively calling this
rule
and of course affiliate payout
is an action
because it called the action and so now
we have to highlight affiliate payout in
main
and then all right now main is a an
action and nothing calls main so
we're done
but
the thing is it's all actions
you have actions at the bottom
of your call stack you know the top of
your calls to everything under that
all the way to main
is going to be actions
and so this is one of the problems that
functional programmers have recognized
in using
actions uh in like anywhere in the code
is that they spread
they they just spread
all
up until main
so you're gonna have actions in your
code we we we need to send that email
like that's what the software is
supposed to do we need to send payouts
but we just have to identify and be
be
conscious
and mindful of where what is an action
so this spreading rule helps us see that
yes if you put action somewhere in there
it could spread all the way and infect
everything
okay
we'll talk about the problems with
actions in a moment
uh first let's talk about extracting
calculations so this is a
here i'm going to turn my video back on
this is a
refactoring
that will let us take some existing code
that's a mixture of actions and
calculations maybe it's it's one big
action and extract out a piece of it
that could be a calculation
so here's a function called show total
it initializes total to zero then it
loops through
the items
in in a for loop
right items is some global variable
somewhere
and it's going to add the price of each
item to the total and then at the end
it's going to
it's going to set the inner html
property of this dom element to total so
it'll show it in the web page
all right so
we can deduce a couple things
the first is that the red
elements are
actions
so let's start with items
so we're reading the value of a global
variable
and a global variable
could change at any time right we don't
um
you know it
calling show total when the items has 20
things in it is going to be different
from calling it when items has 10 things
in it right so now show total depends on
when it is called
because it is reading items
likewise
it is
setting
something in the dom so if we call it
again
i mean maybe this wouldn't change the
dom because you'll get the same total
calling it two times but if we called it
zero times versus calling it one time
that would definitely be a difference so
that part is an action but i've
highlighted in blue
all this other stuff that's not really
an action in here so
uh
this
iteration through the through the items
array
and
updating total adding to total like all
that stuff
does it's going to give you the same
answer if items were the same this total
is always going to be the same so we can
we can probably look at this blue stuff
and try to extract that out as a
calculation
so we do that we make a function called
sum total
and it takes items as an argument
and then we have this for loop in there
now items in here is blue because it's
the argument it once it's passed in
it's not
going to change
because you know we can if we need to
sum a different array we can just pass
it in we don't have to assign it to a
global variable and then it's going to
return the total at the end
and now show total instead of having the
for loop
in line in there
it's going to call
sum total and i made a mistake items
should be red because it is still
reading from the global variable so this
item's thing should be read and then of
course this is unchanged
so notice we've built a calculation
called sum total we've moved a lot of
code out of this action and into a
calculation
now let's go a little bit deeper in what
we actually did here
these two reads to items
these are actually implicit inputs to
our function
they're implicit the explicit inputs to
a function are the arguments but these
are implicit inputs it's data entering
the function
that doesn't go through the arguments
and then we are setting the inner html
property modifying the dom that's an
implicit output the explicit output
would be a return value from the
function
so we have an implicit input and an
implicit output
and
we've replaced them with explicit inputs
and explicit outputs
at least in our
calculation right so this is
the refactoring that we're trying to do
we're trying to identify how does data
enter into the function how does it
leave and only use arguments and return
values to do that and we could just
write it out like this replace implicit
inputs with arguments and replace
implicit outputs
with return values
okay now let's talk about reuse testing
and maintenance
so this
i'm just going to ask it like this like
which is easier to reuse
calculations or actions so when we're
talking about reuse
we are talking about
taking some code and using it
in different departments different run
times so meaning you could run it on the
server in node or in the browser or you
know
what have you
depending on the language you're using
different contexts so
you could
be
running like this sum total to figure
out the taxes that are required
uh for those items or you could be
calculating the total to display into
the dom
different assumptions
like you could be assuming that these
items are
actually in the shopping cart versus
these are items in an inventory
and at different times so you want your
code to that you write today to still
work
in a year and so
if you
tie in the
if you have all these implicit inputs
and implicit outputs
uh you you're
baking in all these assumptions about
the context and the run times and who
needs it for what purpose and by
separating it out and making it into
arguments
and return values
you're actually able to reuse it in
different contexts because it's so much
easier to vary
the inputs because they're just
arguments and there and use the outputs
for different purposes because they're
just return values
so i would argue and i think most
functional programmers would argue
that calculations are just inherently
by definition easier to reuse
which is easier to test calculations or
actions
so actions depend on how many times they
are run and when they are run
and when we're testing our code
we usually want to test it more than
once
right so we might have
we might have 20 100 tests to test one
function
and so we're going to run that function
100 times
so we're already
running it multiple times and then of
course we might run that function
a hundred times in one day every time we
modify some code we rerun our tests and
then when we deploy we're gonna run it
uh in on the build server
and then of course it's going to get run
again in production
and so
these are different places different
times different run times and of course
we want our tests also to
live on and be valid in a year so we
don't have to keep writing them so just
by definition
i argue that calculations are easier to
test
for instance if you wanted to
test our show total that modifies the
dom
you have to set up a dom maybe you have
to mock it maybe you have to always test
that function in a browser that's going
to have a dom for you
and then you have to
like look into the dom to see if it
worked so it's it's much harder to test
than the sum total function
that just has a return value you can
easily
just look at that number compare it to
what you expect it to be and have an
easy test
all right now which is easier to
maintain this one's a little harder
because maintenance
is
more complex
but
usually when we're talking about
maintenance we're talking about changing
context talking about changing
assumptions changing requirements
uh you know changing assumptions maybe
we learn something new about how the
domain is supposed to work
so
when we're dealing with
actions that have these
implicit outputs and implicit inputs
those assumptions are baked into it
about where the data is going to go
where it has to be used
and with a calculation
the assumptions are much fewer
yes you have to assume some things
obviously you have to assume this
items that are being passed as an
argument are
in an array right or they have they all
have a price property yes you have to
assume that stuff
but you don't have to assume that it's
in a global variable that has just been
updated with the
correct items right that's a bigger
assumption that kind of assumption ties
the
size that for loop into
a
particular order
of things executing and that's much
harder to maintain as that as more
things are using and reading from that
items global variable you're just going
to have a lot more trouble
so
that sum total function is just so easy
to just copy paste into a different
context
or import it and use it in a different
context
so i'm just gonna
this one's harder to
to
argue for but i would argue that
calculations are simply easier to
maintain
almost by definition
okay there's much more in part one i've
just talked about three
particular things uh part one we
work with immutable data we look at two
major strategies for working with
immutable data
one is called copy on write and the
other is called defensive copying
we
talk about how to interoperate with
non-functional code using the defense of
copying
sometimes you can't get rid of all the
implicit inputs and outputs and so
but we do show how
even even getting rid of some of them
improves your actions you know having an
action that writes to the dom but it
takes an argument instead of reading
from a global variable that's even
better
we talk about dealing with state that
changes over time
you still need state every application
needs state functional programmers use
state all the time we're just more
careful with it
and we talk about something called
stratified design
this is
kind of a design principle about
structuring your code into layers so
there's a ton of stuff in
in part one it's about
seven chapters
so
i couldn't possibly go over all of it
here so please check that out
i'm gonna move on
to the second level so the first level
was all about distinguishing actions
calculations and data and what's
possible once you make that primary
distinction
that
kind of defines functional programming
the second one is all about first class
values first class functions and higher
order functions once you realize that
you can pass functions to other
functions return functions from
functions
there's a lot of stuff you can do we're
going to talk about some of those now
so
the first thing is just to kind of get
an idea of first class values we're
going to do a refactoring called express
implicit argument
then we're going to do a refactoring
called replace
body with callback
this one is
about syntactic abstraction and then
we're going to
look at how we manage
uh the repetition of actions
so that it doesn't interfere
alright so first thing refactoring
is express implicit
argument
all right so
refactorings kind of are answers to code
smells code smell is a problem in your
code
that's not
that's not
something that you can really put your
finger on
it's not
necessarily a problem but sometimes it
is a problem
so here is the implicit argument in
function name smell so let's imagine we
had these three functions
set price by name set quantity by name
and set discounts by set discount by
name
let's look at the top one set price by
name you notice that it gets
something out of the cart by name
and it calls that item
then it calls object set which is a
function that is going to
update the property of that item
and what property it's passing in the
string price
so it's like the key and then price is
the value that it's going to
set it to price is another argument and
then it's going to set in the cart
to the the name to the updated item
okay now notice set quantity by name is
very similar the only difference is that
set price by name uses a string price
and of course the argument is called
price and then set quantity by name has
the string quantity and quantity is the
name of the argument and
i haven't written it out but you can
imagine that set discount by name is the
same except it's the string discount
instead of quantity
so this is a smell it's very the code is
very repeated the only variations are
the significant variations on this
string that's hard coded in there
and there's another aspect to it which
is that
the name
of the function
is the part of the name at least is kind
of acting
like
an argument it's an implicit argument so
price
is matched with the string price and
quantity is matched with the string
quantity and discount is matched with a
string discount
so there is a refactoring to make this
argument an a real argument
make it an explicit argument
so instead of just being
in the name
we're going to use a more abstract
term that can cover all the price
quantity and discount we're going to
call it field and notice we added an
argument and that argument is going to
go in place of the string
okay i get i'm getting a question that
what language is used in the book
i use javascript
it's a good question
i use javascript
to
to be kind of a universal language
it is not i have to emphasize this it is
not a functional programming and
javascript book i'm not recommending you
do
uh you know that you that fun that
javascript is a great language for
learning or doing functional programming
in
um
but it is
good for teaching functional programming
because
basically because i have to teach so
much whereas in other languages let's
say i chose haskell these would all seem
like language features whereas in
javascript you can actually
you know show how to do it
so it's the language is javascript
because most people can read javascript
if they know c or java or c sharp they
can read enough javascript to to make
progress
okay so back to this
field
becomes an argument
and it's replacing that string so now if
we wanted to call set field by name or
if we wanted to call what we used to
call set price by name we would just
call set field by name and pass in the
string price
we can see that here
we are
calling it with different
with different strings
and now we don't need three functions
that basically do the same thing and
what we're doing is making field
a first class value before it was not
first class it was just part of the
the function name and now it's first
class so that means we can pass it
around we can
maybe even concatenate it together to
make a new field there's so many
possibilities because we can use the
whole language
to um to
to make that
to work with that value
because it's first class now if you were
using typescript i would suggest
you know making a type
that uh
new all of these strings if you're using
java you might use an enum
um i'm certainly suggesting to use the
tools of your language to make this
easier but if you're not you could still
add something in here like a validation
to check field against a list of strings
that are allowed right so there's still
a there's still room for
um
there's still room for safety there
and also
i don't think it's any less safe than
the original javascript
the
you could have typos in the string and
the function name or in the in the
string that gets passed in so it's not
it's not like it's
it's uh
it's we've lost any safety there
okay next refactoring replace body with
callback
so here's the smell
we have these two for loops that
are pretty much the same they're just
iterating through
different arrays and doing different
stuff inside the loop to each thing so
the first one is all about cooking and
eating foods
right it's looping through each food and
cooking it and eating it and then the
last one once you're done eating you
want to do the dishes they're going to
wash dry and put away each dish
right but the loops are basically the
same
so that's the smell
the problem is
we can't separate this curly brace here
from the closed curly brace so we
couldn't just say like take the top part
the first line
and then
make a middle
like make that into one function and
then the middle part make that into a
second function and then the last line
the close curly brace make that into a
third function and so we just call a b c
right we can't do that because we can't
syntactically separate
the curly braces
and every language has stuff like this
where you just
you know you you surround stuff
with syntax and you can't separate them
so how do we do this
well there's a refactoring called
replace body with callback we're going
to name the parts
there's the before part
which is the for loop like the meat of
that for loop there's the closing brace
that's the after
and inside there's the body so the
before and after are red and the body is
green
okay notice
if we ignore the name of that array the
the befores and the afters are the same
it's the body that's different
so we can
uh make a function
that
has the before and after
but it gets passed in the f the function
as the body
so the body can be whatever you need it
to be and of course we're going to make
array a more generic we're going to make
this variable a more generic name than
foods because we don't know what we're
going to call it on an array is kind of
we know it's got to be an array oh and
sorry this should be array.length now
that i'm reading it
but the body gets passed in as f so how
do we use it
on the left this is the original code on
the right we see
that we have a four each we're calling
for each
passing in the array of foods
and we're passing in a function that
takes one food
cooks it and eats it
and
that function that cooks and eats it we
see up here in the definition of for
each it's going to get called for each
element of the array
likewise we can do the same for the
dishes
and
this
lets us abstract over syntax
it lets us
kind of freeze us from writing for loops
for the rest of our lives as programmers
and we can start building higher level
abstractions
something functional programmers do
all the time
okay we're going to move on
uh
okay so here's a problem
actions depend on how many times they're
called
um
that's just built into
i mean whatever
usually it's built into the language
that you're using that you call
something twice it gets run twice i mean
that kind of makes sense
but sometimes we don't want that to
happen here's an example
so we have this function called send
welcome email
and it just
contacts our email server and sends it
you don't need to see the code just
imagine it sends this email through an
email server and of course the
programmers have written a nice warning
only call this once
otherwise the customer will get two or
more emails
which makes sense
but it's just a comment it's not going
to actually prevent this from getting
called
what we're seeing is a conflict between
the way
javascript semantics work we call a
function twice it runs twice and what we
actually want to happen which is only
call this one time no matter what
so
we can we have a solution
notice we're writing another
um
higher order function it's called once
only and it takes a function as an
argument that's what higher order
function means it takes a function as an
argument or and or it returns a function
so let's walk through how this works so
we have a variable
called has run and we initialize it to
false
now once only is going to return a
function
and that function is going to check if
has run is false if it's false it's
going to set it to true and then it's
going to return the function
so the first time it runs
has run is going to be false and so it's
going to call f
sorry sorry it returns the result of
calling f not
doesn't return f
okay sorry so the first time this runs
it's going to
return the result to calling f so it's
going to call it and return it
return the return value
but the second time has run is going to
be true and so this is going to get
skipped
okay
and so now we can define
send welcome email
as
passing this function to only once
right this is the same code we had
before
but now we're wrapping it in this only
once so now we can call send welcome
email as many times as we want if we
call it 10 times it will only run this
email server.send one time
now this is very similar to what we did
before
where we wrapped a function
in the when we did the four each
we are passing the function f
into
this basically into this loop so that it
can get called
for each item in the array but in this
case f we're expecting it to be an
action
and only call once
right and so this way
we are
modifying the time
we're modifying the model of time
now the semantics for this function if
it's been
passed through only once
is
it no matter how many times you call it
it's only going to send at most one
email
so we've we've taken the existing model
of time and
and made our own model of time and this
is something that
functional programmers tend to do is
like rework how time works
and time has actually two
two components to them it's got the
repetition
and the ordering
repetition very simply is how many times
it runs
and there's different ways you might
want to control it we already looked at
call at most once
right
but you might want to call it most end
time so instead of a boolean that goes
from false to true you could count 0 1 2
3 and if it gets to 10 you stop right
you could make something like that
[Music]
also this is something very useful on
the web or other user interfaces
multiple calls in quick succession
result in only the last call happening
so an example of this is if i'm
clicking uh
add to cart add to cart add to cart add
to cart
very quickly uh each one of those is
gonna do some asynchronous activity
you know hit the server
they're gonna come back in different
orders and they're all trying to
calculate the total and then update the
shopping cart's total in the dom
well you only want to calculate the
total for the last item added
not the you know the first one okay
maybe but the middle ones you don't
really need them so
you could uh you could have a model
which we develop in the book
where only the last one
gets run
okay so there's also ordering which is
basically when because in
you know it's not about clock time it's
about when it happens relative to other
things which is just ordering
so one thing you might want is one
action at a time you don't care if a
happens before b or b happens before a
but you want to make sure that they
don't happen at the same time right so
you can
queue them up in some way so that only
one happens
another thing is you want one action to
start
after others finish
so you might have 10 asynchronous things
that need to happen they all gather
these 10 things
you know up and then you want to do
something with all 10 of them at the
same time
so in you might be familiar if you're a
javascript program you might be familiar
with uh promise.all
uh this is a way of doing that
um
but there we develop a way
also in the book
uh and then another one is effects
happen in the same order as causes
right if i'm adding stuff to the cart
and then the ajax requests happen in
different orders
and
so i get i see the shopping cart total
of the third one when i've added 10
things like you don't want that to
happen you want the last one
it's effect of like writing to the dom
you want that to happen in the same
order
as as the causes which are the button
clicks happen
so that's that's another thing
so just to summarize that
because that's kind of a mouthful
functional programmers explicitly manage
the repetition and ordering of actions
this is one of those
things i was talking about where
functional programmers pay more
attention
to actions
that they know that the ordering and the
repetition is really significant so they
are going to spend more time managing
like what is the actual thing that i
need to happen
all right there's more in part two i
just touched on three different things
we talk about functional tools for each
is a functional tool
uh it's basically functional tools you
know
a basic way to put it is
maybe it's it's not perfectly correct
but it's clear and reusable for loops
we're talking about for each map filter
reduce we we develop each of those
and then we chain them together into
data transformation pipelines and this
gives you really concise way of working
with data
sometimes you have nested data so you
have like maps inside of maps
and we have some functional tools for
dealing with those
we talked about some some of these ways
of controlling time we develop a bunch
of primitives we developed one here the
only ones there's going to be more
we also talk about reactive models of
state so you have
state that changes and you want things
to happen every time it changes so that
stuff stays up to date
and this is a way of turning cause and
effect inside out it's like another way
that you can manipulate time
and then onion architecture
this is a
kind of a service level architectural
system to structure your service into
into different layers
okay
um i'm at the end here's more about me
again my name is eric normand my book is
called grocking simplicity
you can find it at that link i have a
blog i have a podcast all about
functional programming
and software design and the history of
programming
right now i'm reading touring lectures
touring award lectures and commenting on
them
i teach closure and functional
programming i have a newsletter
and i'm on twitter wow i do a lot of
stuff
okay thank you very much
um
here is again that coupon code if you
want to get the book
you